in our family. It's very present. It's
very present because we're all very
Catholic and both great events where
Hapsburgsburgs played a role in stopping
the Ottoman advance, the battle of
Leanto and also the siege of Vienna
1683. So Hungarians are profoundly aware
of of the dangers that Islam can pose.
We have to realize how close the Ottoman
Empire and Islam was of taking over
Europe in the 16th century before the
battle of Leanto. They dominated the
Mediterranean. They took Christians
prisoner and used them as slaves. It was
the Venetians of course and several
others who together gathered a fleet and
they all went into battle with the
swords in the right hand and a rosary in
the left hand. And we are supposed to
fight for our Christian values.
>> Thank you for joining me. What I'd like
to start off with is if you can just
briefly tell us, you know, a lot of
people they hear the the word Hapsburg
and they have a vague vague idea, you
know, that it's some sort of royalty in
Europe.
>> Um, and it gets really confusing to a
lot of people and a lot of people maybe
know that it's somehow or other
connected with the Holy Roman Empire. So
perhaps we can start there kind of with
Charlemagne and just give us a quick
summary of what the Holy Roman Empire
was and then what were the Hapsburgs?
How did they fit into all that? um from
that point till the present.
>> Okay. So, thank you for having me on the
show and I love speaking about my family
obviously and uh I I love to explain the
Hapsburg family to an American audience.
I've even written a book about that uh
for an American audience. So the great
thing about the Hapsburg family is that
it is a part of European history anytime
from the 13th century to the 20th
century. Whatever happened there were
always Hapsburgs around who played a
role and um as you're absolutely rightly
said so for a long part of that history
the Hapsburgs were connected to the Holy
Roman Empire. The Holy Roman Empire was,
if you want, a kind of reboot of the
Roman Empire started around the time of
Charlemagne.
It incorporated most of what we would
call Germany today and neighboring
countries down to Italy. So the whole
central part of the European continent
uh down to Italy. The emperor of the
Holy Roman Empire had nothing to do with
the emperor that we know for instance
from Star Wars, a tyrant ruling with
iron fist over uh over several planets.
But it's
>> it was a far more complicated thing. It
was I would say far more akin to um to
the emperor in Dune. uh someone who had
to balance between different houses,
someone who had to play a game of 3D
chess with u a multitude of tiny
kingdoms, dukedoms, uh princoms, keeping
them all together, keeping them under
under one under one roof, keeping the
peace between them while not having a
capital, not having an army, not having
a budget, just your title as the emperor
who was supposed to be the judge between
all these people. It was it was a
terrifying job. Um, and it shaped the
Hapsburg family from the very beginning
very strongly.
>> So, they're a family that is sometimes
connected, sometimes not connected with
the Holy Roman Empire.
>> They started with the Holy Roman Empire,
then they fell out of that club for
about 120 years again.
>> Okay?
>> And then they came back with a vengeance
and remained
>> until the end of the Holy Roman Empire.
So except for a very very brief moment
in the 18th century, the Habsburgs were
always the Holy R Roman emperors. Uh so
far that the double eagle, the symbol of
the Holy Roman Empire became the symbol
and the of the Habsburg family. And what
I usually tell people is that if I can
give you a short run through to Hapsburg
history um 1273 I would I tell people
you need to know five dates to have a
vague idea about Habsburg history. The
first one is 1273. That's when the first
Hapsburg became king of the Holy Roman
Empire Rudolfph. Um the next date I
suggest to people is the year around
1500. That was when the Hapsburgs went
from being rulers in Austria
to suddenly in a very brief span taking
over Burgundy.
after that uh Hungary and Bohemia uh at
the catastrophe of the battle of Moaj
and immediately after that through
marriage politics of Emperor Maxmleon,
Spain and with Spain large parts of the
known world at that time
>> and suddenly they they ruled over uh an
empire where the sun never set as it was
said about Charles V. That was around
1500. Then around between 1500 and 1700
uh a time we're going to speak about
later I understand a lot there were two
branches of the Habsburg family. There
was the Spanish branch and the Austrian
branch. The Spanish branch looked after
Spain and the possessions of the Spanish
Habsuks in the entire world. The
Austrian branch looked after Austria and
the Holy Roman Empire. So Charles the
5th's brother became emperor after him.
That was sort of the the working the
working order that the Hapsburgs divided
the world among them themselves. They
also got married to each other quite a
lot in that time which led to many
people associating Hapsburg with
inbreeding and the jaw.
>> Very important thing I have to make a
present as
>> people usually think that the Hapsburgs
have this gigantic deformed jaw because
of the imbreeding
>> because it's it's one of the classical
uh cliches of history that are wrong. Uh
the Habsburgs got that jaw two
generations before they began.
>> So they do have the jaw.
>> Oh yes. They had for a while from about
1470 to 1700s you had that in many
members of the family stronger
>> as prominent as in those paintings.
>> Yes. But those those paintings again
they got this not from the inbreeding.
Okay.
>> Not at all.
>> Even uh
>> it's just a genetic trait. It's a direct
trait that entered probably through uh
Timogis
uh a Polish princess who married into
the family and she married the
grandfather of Charles the 5th and
that's how it came in. Nothing to do
with inbreeding but of course it would
be so nice but what is true is that the
inbreeding led to uh to the the last
Habsburg of the Spanish France dying in
1700 in a very bad uh health state. So
the Spanish branch died out in the year
1700 and that's the next date I suggest
to people to learn and then immediately
after that for a few years it looked
like the Austrian branch would die out
too because um Charles V 6th Emperor
Charles V 6th uh had no children for 10
years and then he had two daughters and
so that would have been the end but he
had years before made a trip where he
convinced told the electors that he his
children if he only had daughters could
carry on the family tradition by adding
the name of their husband to their own
name. And that was when uh Maria
Theresia in in the 1730s
married Francis of Lorraine
>> and began having uh an incredible amount
of children with him. Since then we're
called Hapsburg Lorraine. And then came
the the famous reign of Maria Theresia,
16 children. Um and then of the brief
reign of her son um Leopold the second
16 children and then there were a lot of
Hubsburgs around again after that
bottleneck around 1700s and then you had
uh the Habsburgs uh in 1806. That's the
next date that I tell people to learn.
1806 the Holy Roman Empire ended. It was
a decision by Francis II of the Holy
Roman Empire who realized that Napoleon
was about to take uh the Holy Roman
Empire for himself. So he dissolved it
>> and that's when that ended and the
Hapsburgs retreated into AustriaHungary
and surrounding countries and had the
Austrahungarian monarchy for
for the next for the next century also
until the first world war and the last
Habsburg emperor was also in my humble
opinion the most Catholic and one of the
most impressive who ruled only for one
and a half years
after France Joseph many people don't
even know that there was a Habsburg
emperor after France Joseph is blessed
emperor Empal who is very loved in our
family and was a great example for all
of us.
>> And these are your ancestors, right?
This would be
>> blessed car is not my ancestor because
I'm from another branch.
>> Okay.
>> There are like four great branches of
the Hapsburg family. I could go into
this but it'll take about 20 minutes.
>> So uh forbear
>> okay
>> because I'm a direct descendant of
France Joseph.
>> Okay.
>> And today we're about 500 members uh
worldwide.
Many of us meet daily on on a WhatsApp
group
>> and discuss things, share images, also
cat pictures, but mostly new births and
articles about the Habsburg family.
>> So that's where we are.
>> Very good. Thank you for that uh
excellent summary. Um you mentioned
Mohawks, the battle of Mohawk, which I
think is in 1521 with the Ottomans.
>> 26.
>> 26, right?
>> 1526. And what's so that really of
course just introduces the whole big
question the next question really which
is the Ottomans the Ottoman Empire that
Islamic massive entity that you know
savage the Balkans and other regions of
course I remember in my studies often
times it would seem that the Habsburg
are like their nemesis okay they they
they appear as their number one nemesis
including in the siege of Vienna in 1683
>> and um also I think in the battle of
Leanto it's a Hapsburg who um Don Juan
Don Don Juan
>> of Charles the fifth son he also plays a
role. So you know what is the living
memory amongst your family and you as
well about all of that long history the
Ottoman occupation the Ottoman invasions
the Ottoman battles the atrocities
slavery is that something kind of we
forgot about that it's no longer
relevant or how does it all digest in
your mind
>> for us in our family it's very present
it's very present because we're all very
Catholic and both great events where
Hapsburgs played a role in stopping
stopping the Ottoman advance, the battle
of Leanto and also the siege of Vienna
1683.
Uh both of these events were deeply
connected to the Catholic faith, to the
papacy, to prayer, to rosary. So for us,
it is also a spiritual event. I'm saying
this because we have to be very clear
that not all Catholic families in Europe
saw it that way. I have to say um that
the French
>> in both of these great events took the
sides of the Ottomans in in um in the
battle of Leanto 1571 they sided with
the Ottomans in order to hurt the
Spanish Hapsburgs
>> and in 1683 they sided with the Ottomans
to hurt the Austrial Hapsburgs. So the
Hsburgs in Vienna um the the Hsburg
family saw themselves as defenders of
Europe. Um
>> defenders of Christendom
>> of Christendom 2 of Christendom 2. And
of course they were very aware of the of
the threat of the Ottoman Empire because
in 1526 a catastrophic
battle of Moaj led to the end um of the
last ruler um before of the Yagalonian
family who was married to a Habsburg and
when he died in the battle of course uh
Hungary and Bohemia fell to the Hapsburg
and that crown fell but they didn't
really mean a lot because a large parts
of Hungary were then occupied by the
Ottoman Empire. Um we're sitting here on
the castle hill of Budapest uh which was
taken by the Ottomans and the Matias
Templeum, one of my favorite churches in
the world uh where Blessed Emperor Carl
was crowned um in 1916 and the flags are
still hanging there. That church was for
about 120 years um a mosque. And uh so
Hungarians are profoundly aware of of
the dangers that Islam can pose. And we
we have to realize how close the Ottoman
Empire and Islam was of taking over
Europe. In the 16th century before the
battle of Leanto, they dominated the
Mediterranean. They took Christians
prisoner and used them as slaves. And
many of those, by the way, had to fight
in a battle of Leanto on the on the side
of of the Ottoman Empire. And as I told
you, it wasn't easy for St. Pope Pius
the 5th to gather an alliance, the Holy
League to fight the Ottomans. And the
Hapsburgs uh of Austria were extremely
cautious. That was Maxon II. He was very
very nervous of um of taking strong
aside in here. So nothing to be expected
from him. It was the Spanish Habsburgs
and it was Don Juan. Uh, and it was the
Venetians of course and several others
who together gathered a fleet and beat
the the the Ottoman fleet at Leanto. Now
for us it's always important to know
they all went to confession before that.
They took uh holy communion mass before
that. And as far as I understand uh dee
Austria said that no one is allowed to
curse during the battle. Um and he will
be anyone who curses will be punished.
And they all went into battle with their
swords in the right hand and a rosary in
the left hand. And they brought a copy
of the image of Guadalupe on one of the
ships into the battle. So it is strongly
carried by spiritual meaning and by a
meaning of Christianity against the
manners of Islam. Also P had a vision of
the outcome of the battle and ordered
all the churches of Rome to to ring the
victory uh long before the message
arrived. He was praying and he saw the
victory and he announced to to the
Christianity that the battle was
victorious long before the message
arrived which took several days to come
to Rome. So it was all seen as a sign of
God protecting
the Christian world. That was the battle
of Leanto.
>> If I may interject. So when you talk
about uh you know all these signs and
religious symbolism and of course uh you
know Christian participation in the
eukarist and prayer I know a lot of
people today will find that mindboggling
that you are associating that with
militancy because that's what was
happening. They were fighting against
the invaders. How does uh and I I
personally of course have no problem
reconciling the two, but what what do
you have to say about that when people
say no, if you're going to be a
Christian and pious and engage in that
sort of thing, then the first thing you
need to do is not fight back and uh you
know, love your enemy and turn the other
cheek. So it seems and it's very obvious
of course if you look at history all
throughout um Christians, Catholics
especially and Orthodox had no
compunction being pious on the one hand
and being very very militant on the
other. Yes. Um so what are your thoughts
on that?
>> Oh well of course as usual as a diplomat
I have very balanced thoughts about
that. I believe that there is something
like a just war. There is moments where
you have to defend uh your your country
where you have to fight to defend your
country. I mean as I said before Leanto
Christians were raided all along the
Mediterranean and sold into slavery.
Will you just accept that and say
>> there was 1.25 25 million European
slaves in Barbary just in that century.
>> I always keep that in mind when people
say that slavery is an invention of of
America.
>> Um and yeah, yes, that is one side and
of course there is there is a
consequence. Uh KL Martell stop the
Islamic invasion in 732 in Tier. Go to a
map and look up how close that is to
Paris. European history would have been
very different. and we are supposed to
to fight for our Christian values and we
have to stand up for them. That was one
of the occasions. Le Hunter was another.
I wouldn't say it was the total game
changer, but it was a first strong strap
to to break the monopoly of the Ottomans
on the Mediterranean. Um, and then of
course there was the siege of Vienna.
Just think about it. If Vienna would
have fallen uh and would have become uh
part of uh of the Ottoman Empire,
think what would have happened to
Europe. It was absolutely catastrophic.
And uh now to tell the story of that
second, in the first battle, a Hapsburg
stood on the battlefield. That was Juan
de Austria. In the second battle,
Leopold the first was a very pious man.
He was a diplomat. He was but he was not
a general on the battlefield. So his
main contribution to that was diplomacy.
Um the Ottoman Empire announced that
they were going to attack Europe in
summer of 17 of 1682
but they couldn't depart them because uh
the marsh would have brought them to the
gates of Vienna in the winter. So they
couldn't do that. So they waited for
spring to depart. And in that time uh
Leopold I made an alliance with Yan
Sububescu of Poland and said if they
attack you we help if they attack us you
help. And um that's how when the siege
of Vienna began it still took a time
>> for the alliance to come together. The
Vienna was besieged for 2 months. I live
near Vienna currently and I'm visiting
those little villages and I'm reading
the stories what has happened to the
people there. It was horrible and you
don't have to even go to Vienna. If you
go to Hungary and you see what the
Ottoman rule did here, um it's clear
that you don't want that in Europe. And
so, uh after
>> Well, can you can you expand? A lot of
people don't know what what what was
Ottoman rule like in parts of Europe
that were um under their control.
>> Well, uh later on, I think in the 19th
or so century, it was a bit more
lenient, but uh in that time it wasn't
possible to be a Christian. Later on,
the Ottoman Empire saw the advantages of
having Christians because they had to
pay extra taxes. But at that time, it
wasn't possible to be a Christian. and
the Ottoman army pillaged and raped and
killed in a terrible way uh through all
of central Europe.
>> Mass enslaved.
>> Yes. And that too. So all of that was
clear. So in the end Leopold managed to
construct this this alliance and here
again the siege of Vienna took two
months uh from mid July to midepptember
until finally the armies came and
liberated Vienna. Every Austrian who
drives across the north across the Dano
looks up and he sees the Ken back and
there is a there is a a church up there
in remembrance of the day when the siege
of Vienna was broken by by the armies.
And here we go again is Yansies, king of
Poland was a real hero and he was a
devout Catholic. He served months before
the attack began, kneeling as an alter
boy um on that hill up there before he
led the greatest cavalry charge in
history. Um that that in the end broke
broke the the Ottoman siege that was at
the point of breaking through into the
inner city. At that point they had
brought their explosives under
>> under the defenses and it was just about
to break and it was seen as God uh
acting on behalf of Christianity and it
was the beginning of the end for the
Ottoman expansion after that. it was
rolled back back. Budapest was liberated
a bit later and then down the balcon.
>> So it's nice to be part of a family that
played that role in those dramatic
times. And now of course later on the
Habsburg Empire had different ways of
treating Islam uh in their midst because
part of the uh Austrohungarian Empire
there were many Muslims there and in the
Austrohungarian Empire army in the first
world war uh you didn't only have
Catholic or Protestant pastors but you
also had immans uh part of that army
because they were Muslim soldiers. So
that was uh a beautiful way of
integrating Islam. But after all what I
told you, you have to understand that
especially Hungary is very sensitive to
the topic of having 10 thousands,
hundred thousands, millions of Muslims
coming into their country because they
have Hungarians are and this is
something we don't have in the rest of
Europe anymore, especially Western
Europe, a very strong historical um uh
conscience. Hungarians are very
conscious of history. If you look at
Hungarians, Hungarian national holidays,
there are two main the three main
national holidays have historic meaning.
One of them was the founding thousand
years ago by King Steven. But the other
two are the 1848
um standing up against the Habsburg rule
and the 1956
uh standing up against uh the Soviet
occupation. Those are big historic
events and they are very present in the
heart of the Hungarians. Every year
people cry for these things like in
Western Europe who still celebrates
historic dates. Hungary is very
conscious of its rich thousand-y year
history and it's a history of being
occupied by different people.
>> So I have an excellent segue here. Um we
were talking about John Soi of course in
the siege of Vienna in 1683 and you were
talking about the Colenberg Hill and all
that. Well, I don't know if you know
this, but apparently Poland had was
commissioned and it made a very large
monument to John Soieski and uh Vienna
had agreed to put it on the hill. And
then only just a handful of years ago
after the the statue was made, the
Vianese city council said, "No, we're
not going to have it because this can
ferment anti- uh Turkish sentiment,
Islamophobia, and xenophobia." So it's
it's actually, you know, created a
little bit of a little scandal between
Poland and um Austria. So that to me is
very telling because here you're telling
me all these stories and their impact
and how important they are and and we
are talking about Hungary. Hungary does
appreciate has a very strong historical
consciousness and you're saying others
like the West don't and I think this
what I just described is a perfect
example. So why don't you um you know
unpack what's going on. Why is it that
western nations which historically are
Christian don't? Um I understand of
course Hungary has a is a special case
because it was under 150 years of
Ottoman rule which is not that long ago.
It's rather recent. Um so that's a
living memory. Is that it? Is that the
only reason or is there something else
going on in the west that has made them
completely capitulate you know any sort
of safeguard against uh you know an
alien entity that's essentially
threatening their way of life and
culture and heritage and religion. I I
think that um due to intellectual
developments of the 1960s and later uh
Europe has lost a lot over the last 60
years. A lot of historical knowledge, a
lot of faith. I have to say that the the
the the faith communities uh the
Christian faith communities, the
Catholic church, the Protestant
churches, they are very weak currently
in Western Europe. They are used to
being in the background and not to stand
out too much in the public sector and
you everybody has become very very very
cautious in speaking about historic
topics. I we have this movement of
toppling toppling statues and even if I
don't agree with a statue uh it stands
for historic events it is a possibility
to debate to have different opinions um
I'm I'm always worried when people
topple statues except of course perhaps
of dictators at the end of a
dictatorship I can understand that but
historic monuments to events that
happened hundreds of years ago
add an negation of history.
>> We are I think we are living in a
culture where the the culture of offense
is so high that you try to tiptoe tiptoe
tiptoe through life. Being a Hapsburg
perhaps is a bit easier because I I can
speak about these topics without any
everybody getting angry and um and I I
will do so in in the future too. But
it's a complicated topic and you know I
was uh I was here in Hungary in 2015
when the huge wave of migrants came into
Hungary. I was here in the summer of 20
that was exactly when I went to the Holy
Sea as ambassador to the Vatican uh for
Hungary. And um and I remember when I
arrived in Rome, uh Pope Francis was uh
was was speaking against people who
built fences against migrants. He was
mostly aiming at Trump, I think, at the
time, but he was aware that Hungary was
building a fence cuz we had 10,000 um
illegal migrants crossing into the
Shenhen area every day uh across a green
border without any control and without
passports and without anybody knowing
who they were. So Europe on the one hand
was telling Hungary and Victor Orban uh
protect the Shenhen area but don't be
nasty to migrants and uh that that
happened. So you have to understand that
the idea to Hungarians for thousands ten
thousands hundred thousands of Muslim u
illegal migrants pouring into Hungary
was especially difficult to swallow
after what happened in the dec centuries
before that. Uh also what we always try
to explain to to Brussels is um we are
not able to integrate a strong Muslim
population into Hungary and its
neighboring visharat countries because
we don't have experience with a Muslim
population since centuries. Uh they're
basically inexistent in our surrounding
countries. And if we look how well
integration worked in Western Europe, um
then we're even more cautious. So that
explains the Hungarian position. Then um
it was very interesting when I got to
Rome to the Holy Sea. I found a very
balanced holy sea. Um the people in the
Secretary of State would not shoot at
straw man. They are extremely balanced.
They are very aware of
the dangerous sides of Islam, the
situation in the European Union and
because they have a nunio on on spot
that informs them. But I remember one
very interesting encounter with an
archbishop uh whose name I won't mention
because it he doesn't cut a very good
figure in this story. um when I arrived
and I you know as an ambassador you go
to holy masses, you go to receptions,
you go to cocktails, you go to you have
meetings and several times whenever he
saw me he said ah Hungary build a fence
against migrants in front of everybody.
So I said I'll I'll have to settle that.
I asked for a meeting with him. I went
and and we had a cup of coffee together.
So, you know, I'm a I'm a very nice
diplomatic person and I tried to
understand what his thoughts were and uh
I said, "So, what do you think about
about Islam?" And we were alone. There
was no one around. So, he said, "Oh, I
think Islam is very dangerous. You know,
they're very nice when they're in a
minority, but as soon as they have the
majority, they suppress everything
else." And and I said, "How do you know
that?" I said, "Oh, I was in Birut for
several years. I know this exactly."
Said, "Ah, really? So how could we
integrate Muslim people into Europe? He
said, "Oh, integration is impossible.
They don't want to integrate."
So I said, "So if Islam in in your eyes
is dangerous and integration is nearly
impossible, why do you want millions of
them pouring into Europe without
control?"
That gave him a pause. You saw he was
actually thinking about the
contradiction.
And then he said, "Well, my hope is that
coming in contact with Western culture,
they will lose their faith and become
black westerners."
>> It's usually the opposite.
>> It's usually the opposite. Uh if you are
in the diaspora, you usually get more
radicalized
>> and uh but just to say I think he was
simply repeating talking points from the
media
>> um without really thinking it through.
>> But I I want to repeat that this is not
the position of the Holy Sea. This was a
very very strong position of this one
person.
>> So the holy sea does have a good idea of
the nature of the potential threat
because Pope Francis didn't seem to.
>> That's a complex and multi-layer topic.
Uh I would say the position of the holy
sea is that wherever it's possible you
should treat refugees
and people who are fleeing nicely and
help them. Every Christian should help
everyone who is in need. That's a very
clear position. Now I would always
answer to that and say that this goes
for every single Christian. But the
state has other duties. The state has to
see that the borders are safe. If the
state has the right, a sovereign state
has a right to decide who comes into the
country and who doesn't. Uh it's like if
you're a father of a family um and you
you're responsible for your house. Now I
could say that you are xenophobe and
perhaps islamophobe. If you have a door
in your house should take that door away
because there is many people outside on
the road who are suffering. You should
take your door away so they can go into
your kitchen and take your food. uh you
don't do that because you look after
your family and then you decide whom you
help and the same goes for the state
must have the right to to have a door
say but of course this is something that
doesn't go with a certain very romantic
view and I have to say that um within
the holy sea there were voices who said
that uh borders should be abolished and
uh borders should be windows and doors
into other places and I remember one
talk with one representative of the holy
see not one of the secretariat of state
who was very outspoken in his in his
ideas who who said in front of all the
ambassadors
uh that whether someone is an illegal
migrant or illegal migrant a refugee
it's all the same because their
experience their emotional experience is
the same so we should help them all and
thank God it wasn't the Hungarian
ambassador who had to say that but the
German ambassador said but there are
treaties there are laws we have to we
have to follow these so there were
around the holy sea a few voices that
had very romantic ideas. Um but the
secretary of state was extremely
balanced
>> in these things and that was always my
experience
>> uh in the last 10 years.
>> Very interesting. Okay. Well, Edward,
thanks uh for joining us. This has been
very telling. Um any final thoughts you
might have? Uh I think we all we have a
few minutes of basically uh distilling
the whole situation down as far as uh
Europe's future especially visv the
migrant qu the migrant question any
final thoughts any last minute hatsburg
wisdom from those seven points.
>> My final thought is to see both sides of
the coin to see the possibility of
integration and to see the the possible
dangers of Islam. Uh I would say the
most important thing is that we are able
to have a open
and truthful debate about this and not
to yell down one side of the discussion
as Islamophobes, fascists or whatever
you want to say and only let the other
side speak. There must be a debate about
this topic. Islam in Europe is a
reality. Uh the difficult sides are a
reality. I hope there is also positive
sides that we can see. But there must be
an open debate and we don't have that
right now. People are being yelled down
if they say something and uh therefore I
that that would be my wish for a
balanced and and good debate.
>> I agree. I think uh once we have a if
people have a chance to speak freely and
that's the whole point and beauty of
free speech then the truth will be
discerned and then ideally we can make
policies based on that. Thank you very
much for joining me Edward.
>> A pleasure. Thank you very much for this
great conversation. I appreciate it.
>> The fire and the rightous name.